hey everybody welcome to live coding
with Jessie and today we're going to
look with git and github and we'll merge
some pool requests in particular we have
two pool requests that I'd like to merge
in our bulletin project that we're doing
with react and if we get through that
and we have a little bit more time then
I have a pool request for a bug that I
had found in the in the Resource Center
project so let's get started so let me
get my my screens in order okay and I
want to apologize I had mentioned on
Monday that I would be streaming
Wednesday obviously I did not stream on
Wednesday so I had completely forgotten
that I had the day off Wednesday so
everybody at the University that I
worked at had the day off so it was All
Saints Day which is a Catholic holiday
and this is a Catholic University so we
have the day off so for anyone who
celebrates All Saints Day or today which
is all souls day then I hope you're able
to make it to mess yesterday and today I
am listening to some traditional music
for all souls there so if anybody
happens to like classical music based on
early medieval poetry then let me know I
can send you some nice Spotify playlists
okay
so hey everybody see some of you are
saying hi there in the live chat okay
great I I just got the the analytics for
showing 0 viewers for a while there and
now I finally kicked in so I think we're
good to start so we're gonna go through
both these pull requests and first thing
we'll do is we'll pull them in on its
separate branch test them make sure
everything's ok well and then we'll
merge them in if we happen to have any
merge conflicts we'll work out those
merge conflicts you know live and
hopefully if you're not that familiar
with git then this will this will help
you out for me at least when I started
working with get just the basic commits
were not that hard but it made me a
little bit nervous when I first started
getting into merging pull requests
dealing with merge conflicts that was
that was kind of like another level for
me so hopefully this will let you you
know get an idea of what it's what it's
like for a real project you know to
bring in code from other people and and
how to handle that without you actually
having to go through this on your own
projects you know and try to learn it
and make mistakes on your own hopefully
I make the mistakes and you can you can
see it and then you don't have to I
don't think will make any mistakes that
these seem pretty straightforward in
terms of pull pull request go so let me
start my Pomodoro timer if you haven't
watched the stream before first of all
welcome thanks for watching and then
secondly I like to break things up
between 25-minute periods of coding or
in this case reviewing code and then 5
minutes a question and answer and then
we just go back and forth between the
25-minute 5 minute periods and then at
the end if there are any other questions
left in the live chat I will answer them
all so if you have a question go ahead
and put it in a live chat now and then
please be patient and
we'll get to it at 1:00 and during one
of those break times or at the end of
the stream probably going to only do two
sessions of coding today got the stream
started a little bit later than normal
just add my whole day almost was filled
up with meetings so just took me a while
to get everything you know I've been
readying at the stream schedule let's
see we're gonna check out if you'd like
to check out the repository so that you
can see the code - in github it's the
bulletin react repository the link is in
the description for the video if it's
not in the description let me know it it
should be and I think we'll start with
the pull request let's go let's start
with pull requests 57 and this is from
Sebastian so we're gonna do a git fetch
origin pool and we're going to do a pull
request 57 since we're put on 57 get the
head and we'll call this and Sebastian
submitting the pull request I'm just
going to put an S there and then let's
see
there's there's several different things
here I like to name my my branches for
testing based on what's happening in the
pool requests for this there's several
things here all right let's just say
styling just in general because a few of
the commits are about styling things
there we go so now we can do a git
checkout and onto that branch that we
just made okay when I switch it Brett
when I pull in a branch to test and I
switch to it I always do a yarn or we
could do at MPM install for not doing
yarn in this case we had nothing to
update but just in case the pool request
added another NPM package we want to
make sure you get that right away or
else we may end up getting some errors
and we might waste time trying to
troubleshoot that when all we needed to
do is just update all right so I'm gonna
go to our bulletin and we'll check it
out specifically let's check out our
print view because this pull request
happens to deal a bit with print you
okay not that so one of the things that
I had at wanted was a close button so I
like that probably what I'll do or if
any of you would like to do it is maybe
move that close button over to this side
it's entirely possible that when I open
an issue about this I said left side
accidentally instead of right side so if
I did I apologize but I think I would
like it better on this side and then
that way we could move our content up a
little bit higher otherwise this is good
and let's
it's attachment code print view button
bug and see
whitespace in a document okay wonderful
I think I think that's all we'll really
need to test out if you notice I do have
the console open so that I see any
errors the only error we're getting is
from an an image that we're trying to
pull in so I'm not worried about that
that may just be something having to do
with either us being a local host or
maybe some problem in our WordPress
installation where that image perhaps it
doesn't exist so in any case this is
okay I'm not worried about this error
and it doesn't look like we're getting
any more errors I could click around
just to be sure great
alright so now the next step is let's
merge this so the first merge I'm going
to make I'm going to merge the master
branch into this test branch I know I've
mentioned this before but for any of you
who maybe haven't heard it before
I like to merge the master into the test
branch first that way if it really
messes things up we haven't messed up
our master branch
we've just messed up the test branch but
if everything's all right there we can
do a check out to our master branch that
means we're just moving to the master
branch and if you're not familiar at all
with git when I say we move to the
master branch that means the version of
the code that we have saved as our
master branch now all our code will
switch to be that version so if we if we
had our code let's say open in the
background here we could potentially
actually see the change happen whoops I
meant to say get check out master now we
can do a git merge and we'll merge that
test branch in
into master and now we get a little
summary of what's happened we've changed
the these following files and it gives
us the the pluses our additions to those
files the read minuses our deletions
from those files so there we go so now
we officially updated it the final step
is to push that code back up to github
which is we're restoring our repository
you don't have to use github if you're
using git it's it's helpful but it's not
it's not necessary so we're gonna do a
git push origin master there we go so
now the code that we've just merged in
is available in our master branch on
github and if you are following along
with the repo pull request 57 should now
say merged it may auto update for you or
you may have to refresh but when you do
it like this on the command line you
push it up you don't have to hit the
merge button on github in your browser
it will automatically say that it's
merged alright so the next pull request
that I'd like to work on is pull
requests 58 okay so
Harshit has submitted this pull request
and it's it's titled miscellaneous
changes but it also closes issue 59 so
issue 59 was opened up by let me double
check this but because I've read it I
think I read it yesterday it was upgrade
material UI and this
submitted by I believe Christian yes so
Christian submitted this and letting us
know that material UI has come out with
a new version and so we should upgrade
to that so harshest has upgraded to that
and also removed the read more buttons
because now on our posts if there is
more to read we have a continue reading
this will be nice because on posts like
this which are really small there's not
really anything else to see so it would
be there there wouldn't necessarily be
any advantage to clicking read more if
you really wanted to see the single page
which is as post you could always click
on the title instead but this will save
some space overall let's see wonderful I
just wanted to test that out and make
sure that we because I hadn't tested
this out for the print view so we can in
fact do print view with a single post
great alright so we're gonna go through
the same process as we did before it
doesn't look like we'll have marriage
conflicts but let me check yeah so get
let me pull this over to see how y'all
can see what git does so I'm on I'm
viewing that pull request and here it'll
let us know it'll scan the branches and
let us know if there will be merge
conflicts so we should be okay I'm still
going to go through the same process as
I did it's just a good practice to test
things out first
so just because there's not going to be
any conflicts merge conflicts doesn't
mean that we should automatically pull
it in right because it may have no
conflicts but we we may not like what
what has happened so there could be no
conflicts in the code but there might be
errors when you
to run it see
okay I happen to look over to live chat
and Arvind says git push origin is
always the same as get push origin
master that's good to know
I can save save some time now and and
typing us a list if I remember hopefully
I remember in about a few minutes when
we go to push this up we'll try to type
it in the shortened way okay and looks
like Sebastian found maybe a little bug
when switching back to normal view it
will always be on grid view
let's see if we got a print and then
click here oh yeah it always goes to
grid okay
Sebastian if you'd like to open an issue
about that then please feel free
otherwise maybe all open an issue a
little bit later on if you didn't catch
that here's what happens
we can choose list view and then we
choose print view and when we go back
out we what should happen is that we
should still be in list view but what
really happens is that we've gone back
to grid view so we'll want to we'll want
to change that and so that was those a
good catch on that Sebastian I did not
notice that let's see here we go alright
so let's go with git fetch origin pool
this is pool requests 58
and this is from Harshit and let's say
material UI since this this pull request
among other things did upgrade to the
new version of it your UI great now
we're gonna check out oops get check out
this and we're gonna run yarn and this
time we do actually have an update for
our package so we should have updated
material UI and material UI icons to the
latest versions okay
it's now let's merge merge the master oh
and do we have a conflict now no it's
just prompting us for a merge message
okay all right so let's just marriage it
there we go and that's just brought in
basically it's just brought in all those
changes that we had just merged into
master it's brought those in to to
update this branch so there were no
conflicts but we needed to update this
so if this looks familiar it's because
we just saw the same thing up here right
here
okay now let's give it a little test so
we really shouldn't say anything let me
refresh this and let's see if we're
getting the same error we are so let's
check out this it's not it's saying it's
a warning so obviously things are still
working here line items crop on a dome
element if you intentionally want it to
appear in the dawn of the customary
spell okay so line items instead okay so
it looks like we have some some props so
since we weren't getting this before we
are getting it now
potentially maybe something changed in
material UI since we updated it and this
is no longer a valid prop so since this
is only a warning I'm okay with merging
this in now at some point we'll want to
fix that but it looks like they've
created by grid component so it looks
like this is having to deal with a grid
and the grid seems to be working so we
can double check that and potentially if
we even are we may have stopped using
the grid for this I think we did switch
to using masonry so we should be okay
everything looks fine and then we should
also there we go so you can see we no
longer have that read more so now that
we don't have the read more I may end up
cutting out some of the padding here it
just seems
more padding that we need but otherwise
not bad
and then eventually what we will do is
once we're actually pulling in data
about with attachments these posts that
don't have attachments this entire
bottom portion will be gone so it'll
save even more space and then only some
of the posts will actually have
attachments okay looks good looks good
just click around just a bit more make
sure we're not getting any other errors
and let's try the search great okay
awesome
okay everything seems to be working
although that's that's odd I have a
space there interesting no there we go
that's really odd huh that was
interesting
I'll have to keep an eye out for that
some empty spaces not a huge issue but
just a little kind of visual glitch I
guess okay that looks good
whoops so let's check how much time okay
great seven minutes let's go ahead and
switch back to the master branch and
then merge this in
I just checked in the live set proxy
says how much longer will this go on I
just tuned in I'm thinking another half
hour at least we seem to be going
through things pretty quickly so more
quickly than than I anticipated but I
think we have at least another half an
hour depending on how many questions are
in the live chat okay
so let's to get checkout master and now
let's merge that branch into master
which should work with no problems git
merge great alright and now we can do a
git push origin okay which I've just
learned is a shortened form of saying
git push origin master if we wanted to
push a different branch we could specify
that but if we just want to push master
I guess that's the default great and
actually let me ask so Arvind is the one
that that let us know about git push
origin is it relative to the branch or
on so for instance if I was on let's say
the dev branch and I did get push origin
would it automatically just push
whatever that branch is so would it push
to dev or is it automatically master I'm
not sure I guess I can try it out at
some point if you don't know
okay but at this point all the code now
is on github it's all up to date on the
master branch and now github says that
branch 58 is in fact merged great so we
have all the outstanding pull requests
should be merged in for this bulletin
react repository not only that but we
have our issues here that have been
closed so let's check this uh let's
check out at close icon to print view
and I do want to see if okay
I okay so I didn't mess that up I did I
thought I may have messed it up and said
left corner okay see this
maybe maybe I'll leave this open and
then I'll close it whenever I put that
in the right corner or if any of you
want to put that icon in the right
corner but it looks like 51 52 let's
check out pool requests or I'm sorry
issue 52 there we go so this vertically
align that attachment icon so before
this icon and the texts were kind of off
in the alignment so let's close that
close that issue awesome and let's also
see this upgrade this was closed so
Christian and actually it was already
closed this was close
I suppose automatically then so we've
gotten rid of those issues and let's
double check okay we can go into our
projects now so we're using this kind of
Kanban style to track some things and
now we can move this over to complete it
and it looks like I'll need to add some
more in here we're getting kind of low
to do so I have to go through and check
that out see what else needs time okay
great so about two minutes let me I want
to take a look at the live chat now
before we start on on the next pull
request we do have a pull request for a
previous project and we're gonna we're
going to bring that in and that one's a
little bit more technical I guess and
because it deals with with forms and
bugs with older browsers and things so I
don't want to try to explain that with
two minutes left so let me go ahead and
take the break now and I'll go to the
live chat and after there's five minutes
is up
we'll do some
or some more merging of pool requests
let's see Jess seems says how long have
you been with get I guess so I guess
that was how long have I been using git
for three or four years yeah somewhere
around there
Musa says how to get started with github
what check out there there are a couple
of courses that are free online that can
help you learn about using git and
github I recommend if you want more of a
structured course I definitely recommend
Udacity intro to get in github really
III think the course is very well done
so check that out it's a mix of text
video hands-on assignments I I really
benefited a lot when I took that course
early on when I was just learning also
if you like videos this channel free
code camps YouTube channel has a series
of videos on git
and I believe that code Academy has
something on get now I'm not positive
and then there are also YouTube channels
that have some git tutorials
I think learn code Academy does have
some good videos so you can check that
out as well so that would be it'll be my
suggestions github itself has tutorials
documentation and things like that you
could read through if you prefer you
know just read through and try things
out on your own
see see s what time is it over there and
my time zone it is 3:30 p.m.
proxy s have you ever done merging /
resolving merge conflicts using github
desktop instead of command-line I've
actually never used github desktop so I
really can't like I can't say anything
about it so the answer is no I've never
done it for me the the command line
seems to be pretty quick I can get
things done quickly I never have to
leave the command line
although when dealing with complex merge
conflicts I could see how maybe it might
be helpful to use something like github
desktop I've never tried it though it
has anybody use github desktop at all or
and particularly when it comes to merge
conflicts if you have let me know I'd
love to I'd love to hear about it
Sebastian says missed the right corner
part yeah no worries Sebastian is cool
yeah that's not really a big deal that's
easy easy fix
oh man Arvind said I left my job by the
way
Oh Arvind what some so how did that go
are you are you I don't know if I should
be sorry to hear that you left your job
or excited I guess it depends on whether
or not you like that job and what your
what you're doing now so was are you
happy about about leaving was it a bad
situation and you have anything lined up
now in terms of terms of a job anyway
let me know and actually for anybody
who's looking for work occasionally I do
have or I hear about some projects that
are open for freelancers
so let me know if you're interested and
then if I find something that fits your
skill set I could always you know let
you know about it I can't guarantee
anything I just I'm not actively looking
for work but occasionally people get in
touch with me about you know some job so
let me know also if you tweet and you
tagged me in this week saying that hey
here's here's what I do you know let's
say I'm a rack developer or I do PHP or
whatever and I'm looking for work
I can retweet that for you I don't have
a ton of followers I think I've maybe
like 600 or something 700 I don't know
somewhere around there but potentially I
could retweet you and you know some
other people retweets you could reach a
large audience so pretty much everybody
that follows me is a developer of some
sort so I'd be happy to help you out in
that way because I know some of you are
looking for work so just let me know
alright my five-minute timer is up but
I'm nearly to the bottom the live chats
I think I'll do one more question who
are vine says the net ninja has a great
tutorial forget and github so I haven't
I haven't used that tutorial yet but
Arvind says it's good so check that out
as well that's the net ninja Oh Igor did
ask about my github black theme yeah
it's actually it's a strip so I use this
tampermonkey plugin and that's that's a
chrome plug-in so you load tampermonkey
and then search for github dark which
rook has as paste it in a link to that
it is github dark so that that is the
correct link Brooke thank you for that
and then just follow the instructions on
that repository and you'll be able to
get the github dark theme and it also
comes with some cool options so see we
have settings here you can change it up
I actually recently changed up my github
theme to this Monica Space Gray 80 so
you know you could do we can change tab
size nice
I'm definitely setting it to two because
that's that's what I like
anyway great that's cool
all right so CFS if I stream after work
I usually don't stream after work
because then I'm home and my my network
is not good enough at home my internet
is not good enough to stream in 1080p I
don't like to stream at a lower quality
because it makes it hard to read the
code so usually I can't even get 720
most of the time too so until better
internet becomes available where I live
I probably won't be streaming from home
I'd love to be able to what just doesn't
it's not working out right now let's see
okay now I'm gonna go back and we're
gonna merge in another pool request
after that I'll go back to the live chat
and and answer some more questions
that's whoops and I just realized that I
have my phone plugged in and when I have
my phone plugged in there's some
feedback often on the mic so so I sorry
if anybody heard some weird feedback
going on there but it should be fine now
all right so let's go first of all let's
bring up this other project which I
think I'm running on localhost 3,000 won
fees one of these there we go
so I already have it up here and here's
the problem so the problem that we had
which I think I mentioned last week is
when you went to submit a form so let's
just bring up one of these forms this is
we have two forms one is a little bit
more complicated this one is the the
simpler of the two so you go to fill out
the form
and you hit submit and nothing happens
this bug was found on safari 9.1 on a
Mac so unfortunately the bug was found
by the head of my department which is no
good right I don't want she was very
very nice about it she wasn't mad at all
in fact she had thought that she was
doing something wrong so but it's
entirely not her fault it just it
doesn't work so I had mentioned that I
thought that it had something to do with
our use of a single weight and it seems
like that's the case that that was the
problem so let's let's pull in the fix
so let's go to let's get our
notifications and yeah this was the
issue and let's find the pull request
all right so what's this he'll let me in
the media Craig is let me open up so
Helder has submitted this pull request
so thank you very much for this and
you'll see in the files that have
changed I know it's really small so let
me zoom in a bit some of these basically
most of these changes are because of
formatting which is weird because we
should have Auto formatting happening
but anyway so let me scroll to the
actual file that that did change so if
you see here we went from using a sink
right so we're using a sink to using
just a normal promise with our with our
fetch okay so that's what I suspected
needed to happen and let's download this
test it out and hopefully it'll work
we're going to use browser stack to do
some testing because we need that Safari
9.1
I see Igor just asked what's the lowest
Safari version you're supporting with
this project to be honest with you I
wasn't worried about supporting older
browsers because this is an internal
project and everyone working at the
University should be getting updates on
their browsers so I generally don't
worry about supporting older browsers
because I think it's bad practice in
general for internal websites because it
just enables users to not update their
browsers which potentially could have
you know security issues but in this
case since it's the head of my
department that was having issues I need
to fix this
and I haven't had any complaints from
anyone else so I don't know if other
users happen to be using that same
version of Safari but it's entirely
possible that they are so I'm just gonna
fix this okay and by me I mean
Helder is going to fix this I did do
some some testing in research on the
issue before I made before I made the
issue on the repository but as you can
see Helder actually did the the work
coding so let's see what was a 65 ok so
let me let me bring over the terminal
window for this so we do have you know
what I have some changes that I had
already made where am I at
it's good or bulletin and then an a
Resource Center that's we're at so the
project is Resource Center let me undo
all my tests because I've messed this up
pretty thoroughly alright and let's do
let's do the status you story about yes
no I have not updated this if you're not
sure what I'm doing I'm trying to get
rid of my my test my changes because I
don't want those to be to be committed
or included at all let's see what it
says I've changed
mmm project description
that's interesting so what does it think
it was I'm gonna give a git diff to see
what changed okay that's interesting it
says that I've actually added this line
in interesting
and I don't really want that at it in
right I do not so let's see what I want
is that to say story and not project
description so let me go actually could
it be
so I'd you have to date that's all
that's really odd I thought I had fix
that at some point anyway let's just go
ahead and change that back then there we
go
know what we should have when we do it
get status is that nothing is here so we
don't see that little asterisk anymore
so that means nothing's there
okay great let's do a git fetch origin
pool and this was sixty five I believe
we can always double check sixty-five
yep and and we'll do let's see so and
let's go sorry bug
so now we're moving to that branch and
we're gonna type in you are in just to
be sure although it shouldn't do
anything okay great now let's merge
master which is up to date so awesome
so everything's up to date now here's
what we're gonna do I'm going to run and
rock which where's my end Rock server
ads maybe I have it on here instead so I
have been grubber running somewhere or I
had it running I stopped it from the
last time there we go okay so what end
rocks gonna do is this is gonna allow me
to test this from anywhere so I'll paste
I'll go ahead and paste this in the
description in case you want to test it
or I'm sorry in a live chat so end rock
is now giving me a link to this even
though it's running locally now you all
can can test it out
I'm gonna run browser stack so if you're
not familiar with browser stack it lets
you run your sites test out sites on
different operating systems different
browsers so oops oops I forgot I was on
Chrome Canary let's try browser stack to
be a lot easier to login like this okay
so I'm already logged in so here's
browser stack let me zoom in a bit so
you can see so I have a choice to run
this on you could see a lot of different
mobile devices but I'm gonna go down
here to Mac and let's try El Capitan so
we're gonna go 9.1 on El Capitan and
it's actually going to start up that
browser device combo
once that starts up we're going to visit
that end Rock link that I just pasted in
and we're gonna try to submit that form
so for me it I had a previous anger
uplink in that obviously is not working
now because I shut down that that link
great so now we're in as you can see
we're in here I can from in here I can
inspect so you can see I can bring up
the dev tools the Safari dev tools and
inspect things and the console will be
most helpful to us I suppose so I'm
going to go into that suggest a story
form since it's a lot easier to fill out
any other form and there's a slight lag
but I'm when I'm doing this but it's not
unreasonable and do the tests and submit
Oh interesting take their object entries
is not okay so we are getting an error
here I can I have my email open on
another screen so I can tell whether or
not an email was sent or whether the
error completely stopped it it looks
like it's completely stopped all right
so I know this is really small can't the
zoom is not working for me so let me
bring this whoops
again let me just read off this error
then so we have a type error object dot
entries is not a function so it says an
object dot entries this state form
object entries is undefined
so let's check that out in the code so
we have our story j s and down here
where we're doing our handle form data
this is where we have object auto
entries this state form so interesting
just rnjesus undefined
I wonder
nothing huh
that's interesting
is all right so here's what I'm thinking
maybe object thought entries is not
supporting
well this just
let's check it out in the mdn and it
should tell us here at the bottom when
we could use it okay so the
compatibility here says it's available
in Safari 10.1 we are testing in 9.1 so
that would make sense okay so it seems
like seems like we need a polyfill right
we employ polyfill listed below
let's see if we can just copy this
polyfill and and get it to work just I
mean this will just kind of really tell
us where the problem is I suppose let's
hear that let's see
okay
so we should be able to go back to our
browser stack this should have Auto
refreshed okay Blake has a question here
I just noticed asking what is the
polyfill do okay so let's let's go over
this nice this is a really great
question so a polyfill is a way for you
to use some newer syntax with older
browsers so let's just check out what
this particular polyfill is doing so its
checking to see if object entries
doesn't exist so you know we see that
exclamation point there which is
basically just the opposite so if object
dot entries doesn't exist meaning it's
not supported by that browser then we're
gonna create objects thought entries so
essentially it's just making it anyway
and then it's making a function that
takes in an object okay so it's going to
do object keys on that object all right
it's basically going to do pretty much
the same thing as object dot entries
would do but it's using syntax that is
acceptable for older browsers or it's
using you know other other methods so
the objects talked keys that's
acceptable for older browsers so when we
add this in which should happen and
we're going to test in a second is that
on newer browsers this will completely
get skipped over and everything will
work as normal but on browsers that
don't support object auto entries
instead this function will run and it
should return something that will allow
our our forms to work properly even if
it's in an older browser so I believe
from what this was saying that this will
not work in older versions of Internet
Explorer I have no intention of
supporting older versions of Internet
Explorer so I'm not worried about that
but it looks like there are some
alternatives if you do need to support
older versions of ie so hopefully that
made sense if anybody else has some more
insight on what polyfills are what they
do
please put it in the live chat now
always appreciate expertise from from
you all so
let's let's try this out again
test I submit error no that Asian growth
is not allowed to sway insecure content
from end rock
all right let me try this so let me try
it another length and then test it again
so it looks like there was some issue
because I was using HTTP so let's go
with the non HTTPS or just the regular
HTTP link and give it another shot see
if that makes a difference but we
weren't getting the object out entries
error so I'm assuming that that was
corrected but we'll try to verify and
get an actual submission to go through
okay now let's submit mmm so nothing
happened and we get no errors in the
console alright I don't like this this
is no good
let's check their network see what's
happening sure story we should be
sending where's our fetch
Eloisa upload URL and we defined it up
here story form so are we actually
submitting sorry for this being so small
error occurred
okay now we finally get an error let's
see what it was
okay so it looks like it's a access
control origin thing why are we sending
these
I saw
alright let's double check our server
you know what this is the one where
we're sending with SendGrid correct
probably what's happening is I have a
whitelist of domains when my SendGrid
api and i don't have this domain
included so here's what I'm gonna do I'm
gonna copy this let me copy this add it
to the API and then we should we should
be okay so I'm gonna do this on my other
screen for SendGrid just so that I don't
accidentally show something on YouTube
that I should not in terms of user data
but basically what I'm doing here is
just adding a URL to the whitelist
for for this particular API key that I'm
using so if you if you want to know how
I'm doing this insane grid you just log
into your send grid account and then on
your side menu you go to settings and
then API T's and then you just select
the API key that you would like to edit
and it's your key interesting
maybe I don't
domains that's interesting it looks like
I don't have the API key setup with any
type of whitelist
interesting okay um then that's crazy
all right so what is the problem
hmm it might be it might be the way
we're running this server actually
you know what let's it it probably is
that let's shut this down and let's go
okay so it's been a while since I worked
on this project so I had forgotten that
the way we're running this is there's a
server running on there's a version of
the site running on localhost 3000 and
in this case 2001 and that one works
except the forms don't work but then we
had another one running on port 9000 and
that one worked with the form so that is
probably our error so my 25 minute timer
is just ended but I want to do one more
test since we're so close
I'd say let's submit this and see what
happens
okay so so far nothing
get xhr
all right well
we're not getting anything
hmm
and we're not getting any errors in the
console
that's odd
oops
let's try one more thing one more thing
before we stop
this is
you see this
let's let me check out our package.json
file and see okay so we should be
starting those servers rights
starting soon
hmm
let's build
okay so I'm gonna run this I'm gonna try
one more time no matter what happens
this next time I'm gonna go to finish up
with some question and answer stuff I'm
not I'm not gonna go through the process
let's say this works I'm not going to go
through the process of actually merging
the same we've already done it twice I
don't really think there's there's much
value in doing it again
the only difference would be after I did
all this
I would then actually go on to the
server and update the the live server
okay so let's let's do sure
okay
it's double-check
okay great that is working and where's
where's our browserstack there it is
okay I'm gonna go ahead and do a refresh
just to make sure it should Auto refresh
on us but I just want to make sure
everything is is working properly
that's omit all right okay says your
story suggestion was sent successfully
okay
and I will verify by checking my email
that I am I should be getting an email
update somewhere
see
so I've gotten nothing so far but oh you
know what
since we're in testing mode it's
probably turned off so that's why I'm
not actually anything you know but we
did get we did get a success message so
I'm happy with that awesome
so with just you know we had to add that
polyfill in there which is okay what
I'll have to do then it's not exactly
ready to merge in yet because I'll have
to add the same polyfill in for the
other form there's probably a better way
to do that so I don't have to repeat the
same code so maybe I'll I don't know
I don't mind repeating something twice
if I had to repeat it more than twice it
might be worth it to maybe make it a
separate component and put it in the
utils folder we'll see but I'd have to
do that then merge it put it on github
I'll put it into the server so if
anybody's interested in that whole
process maybe I could I could show that
on a stream in the future just let me
know but otherwise I think that the
problem seems to be solved so thank you
again
Helder for that pool request and so if
anybody feels like browsing this site on
internet or on safari 9.1 it'll work now
so alright so let me scroll up a bit to
where I left off in the live chat and
answer as many questions as I can
see
okay cool so I if you remember earlier
in the stream
I was asking Arvind about his work
situation since he said he just left
left his job
Arvind says I've decided to learn from
you and do some freelancing it'll give
me a more time to learn all right that's
awesome that's all I mean hopefully
hopefully I can help out with that and
you'll learn there and some things feel
free to you know ask me what you know
whatever you want to you can message me
on Twitter or you know or whatever we're
just asking the live chat I'm happy to
help and freelancing is it's nice if you
get some steady clients it can we it can
be really nice Seif says I'm doing the
same as you and my life hasn't been
better pure happiness for now awesome
that's awesome I'm glad to hear that
okay Musa says I must leave now thanks
for the tree man good afternoon so I'm
sure moose already left but in case that
you watch this recording see you later
and thanks for watching the stream and
then joining in the live chat I
appreciate it world says browser support
like Internet Explorer or Safari makes
me want to leave web death I feel like
I'm fixing fixing VHS for a living yeah
I'm not really I don't really like
supporting older browsers either but
luckily I don't really have to that much
so I think I have it better than than
other people in that regard so it could
be a lot worse but yeah I really I don't
really honestly Internet Explorer does
upset me sometimes with just the weird
errors but to be honest with you Safari
is pretty bad too especially on mobile
Mobile's hearty is like I think right
there in the running for worst browser
to have to deal with as a developer if
anybody on the Safari team is watching I
apologize I don't mean that in any way
to belittle your work or anything but I
just happen to have had a lot of bugs on
mobile safari was some of the stuff that
I built
hmm this is interesting Arvin says I
learned UJS as I found it easier than
angularjs and guess what I don't find I
can't find any jobs for view developers
in India that's actually I mean that's
interesting I've always wondered about
view I know a lot of people like view
but I don't frequently see if you
mentioned in job descriptions now I'm
I'm not really looking at that many job
descriptions but I I don't recall it
being mentioned often so I kind of
wondered what you know what the job
outlook was like for view developers
excuse me Dion I'm highly caffeinated at
this point so I was surprised by the
yawn uh-huh okay I guess that's good to
keep in mind I mean of course this is
anecdotal which it's in no way a study
of you jobs but I have kind of wondered
about that
all right look says the can I use site
it's pretty nice for browser support
information
let's end this session yeah if you
didn't if you've never used can I use
before its it's simply can I use comm
you type in what you want to do and
normally I almost always find what I'm
looking for for some reason I couldn't
find object entries but it works for
JavaScript stuff like this or even CSS
like let's go like flexbox right so you
don't have to specify you just type
something in you'll get the JavaScript
and CSS and you know it'll show you what
it's supported with so we want to use
flex and CSS it'll say you know okay
Internet Explorer 11 as partial support
even explains what that means and looks
like all the other browsers have full
support so really useful super fast to
search through I use this often
okay Igor says it should be a lot of
freelance tasks or outsource projects on
UJS okay
yeah that's that's a good suggestion you
know maybe there's not full-time
developers it's possible there's not a
lot of those jobs but you know
freelancing you know temporary projects
I guess are a way to go oh okay
Sebastian noticed on that bulletin
project that when you click on continue
reading that is also only in grid view
let's see actually now that I'm clicking
this Sebastian and it looks like though
I'm sorry I clicked the wrong thing let
me let's go to continue reading or yet
need to find something that says
continue reading oh you know what
continue reading only video oh I see
what you're saying now actually that's
how I want it so currently on the site I
have it so that in this list view there
is no continue reading the entire text
appears so that's actually how I want it
because I had complaints initially I had
complaints from users because they
wanted to be able to just scroll through
and see everything and not have to click
to read more so what I did as kind of a
compromise was in the grid view because
these cards were more narrow and you
could potentially have a very long
scroll if there are a lot of there's a
lot of content I left that with the
continued reading but in the ListView we
show everything the full content
so it that actually is how how it's
supposed to work but Sebastian you have
great like attention for detail yeah
that was that was pretty good about
noticing that
arvin says what freelancing website
would you suggest apart from freelancer
igor says have you tried up work let's
see I I I have not tried up work I know
you're asking you're having a
conversation with Igor on there but in
case you know anybody else wants to join
in here I'm just kind of reading it out
a bit I have not tried up work so I
can't vouch for that
I have tried freelancer I didn't have a
great experience with it it seemed to me
like the the pay was just way too low
for a lot of the projects there's a lot
of competition a lot of people trying to
you know undercut in bid lower than
other people I didn't find it to be
really worth my time unless I really
didn't have anything else going on so I
didn't like it I I think it's more
promising some of the sites like top Tao
basically any site where they you bet
you have to test to be accepted as a
developer so they only take quality
developers you can pass the test and
then they match you up with companies
who are actually willing to pay you know
a fair amount of money to get a good
developer so if you can find something
like that either top towel word
something that that operates like that I
think that's that's the best bet if I
ever go back to freelancing I will
probably do that yeah that's so that's
kind of my advice about freelancing
if you the thing about freelancing III
talked a lot about freelancing
last week so I'm not going to talk a lot
about it now but I'll just say
freelancing is about selling yourself to
a certain extent so you're not going to
be able to spend all your time coding
and learning if you want to actually
make money you have to sell yourself if
you're not comfortable with that you
almost have to be a marketer in a sense
but if you're not comfortable with that
freelancing may not be for you unless
you can find someone a company like top
Tao or maybe a small business or
something that will be the middleman you
know kind of the go-between between
clients and and you they can handle
contracts they can handle payment things
like that that'll allow you to spend
your time doing what you want which I
assume is coding and not worrying about
the you know these other things so for
me that's more of the ideal freelancer
situation because you know while I do
have experience with marketing and
things I I'd rather not I enjoy the
coding more so anyway just something to
keep in mind
world said I like how you say
interesting instead of cursing like I do
yeah so I assumed that you'd said that
whenever I got the error in the console
that yeah so i i purposely never occurs
on this stream I know I have some
younger viewers so I I wouldn't want to
expose them to any words that their
parents may not want them to hear and
potentially I may have older viewers
that just would prefer not to hear that
language so I like to keep it PG rated
or GE or whatever so anyway yes so you
will not hear me curse on this stream
and I have four little kids so I get a
lot of practice at controlling my
language even when I get upset about
something so when I'm not streaming
though I I have I have said some sub
curse words at the computer like I have
an office with my door shot and
everything so there's no danger of the
hangover earth
my my Spotify playlist has ended so got
to put another playlist on it's really
weird to try to do the stream with
nothing in the background see
Michael crow says take your break now if
you don't you'll be banging your head
against the wall for the next hour
trying one more thing you're right if
that if that last thing hadn't have
worked I I was definitely in danger of
doing just that you're a smart man
Igor says that thing always happens one
more thing one another thing in oops you
have been working for a couple hours
without a break yeah that's true I don't
know how many times my wife is called
and said when are you gonna come home
from work it's getting late and I say
okay I'm working on this I'm just gonna
try one more thing and yeah and then I
end up being here for much longer okay
world says you too man so 49 users
should be grateful cool I hope so
I'm gonna have to next time I see the my
department head I'll tell her that it
now works should be should be happy okay
Blake says by the way I messed around
with figma the wire framing tool it's
not bad okay cool so at some point maybe
last week sometime we were talking about
free wire framing tools I believe we
were specifically wanted ones that
worked for Windows and figma came up so
for any of you that we're in on that
conversation or interested in wire
framing tools for Windows that are free
check out figma fi GMA Brooke says
what's your opinion on stricter linting
rules like the Airbnb preset for es lint
I I don't know I
to me the linting rules I like the idea
of linting rules right so you know like
on our on a lot of our projects we've
set up some linting rules we even have
the auto formatting
that enforces things like that and I
like that it brings a lot of consistency
in particular the Airbnb rules I don't
really have a comment on that because
it's been a very long time since I've
even looked at them I don't really
remember too much of what it is so but
in general you know stricter Lanting
rules I don't have a problem with as
long as they don't slow down development
significantly so I don't mind like when
we're doing the auto you know the Auto
formatting with standard J s and
prettier I'm okay with that
people you know can do whatever they
want in terms of how they code and then
it just gets when they go to commit it
just gets converted to how I want it
that's okay yeah I would say it would
almost depend like on a case-by-case it
depends on like what are those rules in
particular and really it's it'd be more
of a personal thing if the rules were a
lot of things that bother me then I
wouldn't like it but if the rules are
really specific and happened to be like
just how I like things I'd probably be
okay with it so I haven't actually given
that much thought to it this is kind of
just off the top of my head but I'm not
I'm not opposed to strict linting rules
but it just really would depend on you
know what what are those rules in
general I I liked spaces and not tabs so
two spaces I don't like to use
semicolons
I like having properties like if we're
talking about react you know properties
on diff separate lines I think that
makes it a lot easier to read it does
make the code longer but is you should
be keeping your components as short as
possible so assuming you're doing that
it helps with readable
in the length isn't too bad so that's my
preference what do you all think I mean
I like em what do you all think about
what we have set up now I mean I've
really been liking the kind of the Auto
formatting rules that we have set up
well you know what do you what is your
opinion on it I definitely like to know
Oh Igor says we just switched to that
those rules they are awful all right so
we got one vote for awful in terms of
the Airbnb rules
oh okay so Sebastian says I'm looking on
when you click on a category or other
button in the tour it shows of red or
blue color oh okay yeah it does
so we definitely want to change that you
know what I have noticed that before
okay yeah so we definitely want to
change that I'm actually okay with this
grey color that you can see right now
it's showing as opposed to the red the
grace fine with me or one of the colors
that we're already using in the color
palette would also be be okay with me so
thanks Sebastian
okay so Sebastian notice it's just for
the ones that are link component okay
yeah I was to check that out person says
hi I'm new hey how's it going thanks for
joining us in the in the live chat and
welcome Robert says I created a dinner
if anyone wants to join if we have
questions or can help each other outside
of the live chat Jesse let me know if I
can share the link yeah go ahead and
share the link that's awesome yeah we we
actually have
we have a slot channel 2 and I I have
not gone through the process to be able
to efficiently accept people into that
slot channel I know there's a way you
can set it up so that I would just
automatically let you get an invite and
I just haven't really taken the time to
do that yet so if you'd like to be a
part of that your best bet maybe is to
just send me a message let me know what
email you want to use to sign up until I
can get that and but gator sounds cool
though to use because then we wouldn't
have the issues in terms of invites that
we have with slack
now a Blake says my mom would appreciate
that I'm not sure what that was in
response to was that he said something
in the chat or something I said so I
don't let me know Sebastian says
submitted pool requests to fix what you
said about the close icon and fix up the
bug of the grid all right awesome
Sebastian thank you so much that was so
quick I really appreciate that
oh okay Blake says the language all
right okay cool so that was I mentioned
earlier that I don't use any bad
language or cursing on the stream one
reason being for younger younger viewers
I don't know that their parents would
appreciate that
so yeah yeah I personally don't have an
issue with with cursing but I would have
an issue with someone cursing around my
children so I'm definitely sensitive to
that so I'm always I don't know about
you all but I'm always amazed at what I
hear some people saying around their
children like in public I don't know I
mean I guess it's just what you were
used to growing up but I don't know my
mom never said a curse word I only heard
my mom say curse word one time our
entire life as we almost got into a
wreck and so she said it
my dad was he cares a little bit more
but never almost never anything like
really vulgar you know but anyway yeah I
just I think it's a good it's a good
skill to be able to have to control your
language based on who your audiences or
what situation you're in I it just kind
of shows like an element of self control
and
being able to control your thoughts so I
like I like to see that in a person like
that that ability
see
all right seems like I've I've gone
through everything in the live chat so
yep if I happen to miss your comment or
question I'm sorry about that I do try
to get to everything but occasionally I
miss something so if I did feel free to
reach out to me on on Twitter or any
other social media that you can find me
on or just you know come back for
another stream and ask me okay Blake did
ask can you do a live stream on
deploying a react website yeah I
definitely can oh actually I'm so glad
that you that you said that so I have
more information for you all in regard
to this bulletin website we've been
working on so for the last for the last
maybe two weeks or more I've been
talking about the the login system so
currently we have set up
Harshit set it up a password this login
system that uses a link that you get by
email what I'd like to do is to tie it
in with the university's single sign-on
system that they're using for other
things I talked with one of the meetings
that I had today was kind of an
unexpected meeting but I ran into some
of the people in the IT department who
are in charge of the single sign-on and
I asked them what they thought and
what's gonna happen is over the
Christmas break for the University so
the end of December they're going to
switch everyone over to using office 365
for the email and calendars and
everything like that at that point
everybody at the university is going to
have their own Microsoft account they're
on office 365 account and they're going
to have to change some of the way they
do single sign-on so what makes the most
sense for this project is to wait until
that happens and then what we probably
wind up doing is having something come
up that says like sign-in with your
office 365 account and then we'll have a
check server side
to say are they using a Franciscan ddu
address if so then go I go ahead with
the office 365 sign-in if not then you
know give them a message saying hey you
need a franciscan address I think that
that that man that being the best way to
go about it and possibly the simplest
way because I'm sure there's already
some code out there for using sign in
with with office 365 or with your
Microsoft account and react it seems to
me like that would be something that
people are doing somewhere so so that's
what's going to happen it doesn't need
to happen and so you know December
probably January probably sometime in
January it'll happen so we've got a lot
of time to think about it and to look
for a solution and get that ready but
what that does mean is we potentially
could wait and not release this newer
version that we've been working on until
then or we can release it now with our
our email link so we're gonna have to
make a decision with that either way we
have a lot of time now to really work on
this and get it to a point where where
it's how we like so we may slow down on
this switch up to some other projects
there's definitely time if we want to
think about extra features that might be
cool we have a lot of time so we
essentially have like two two months
potentially two and a half months now to
work on this so I mean impotence this is
really it's functional now I mean I I I
don't I wouldn't release it right now
there's still some things like the
filter by date doesn't work and there's
there's some things that I would change
like design wise just really minor
adjustments but potentially like you
know this is the
ninety-five percent operational at this
point so anyway basically what I'm
trying to say is we got a lot of time to
work on this now so if anyone has any
ideas for features that could make it
better I'm open to considering them
I can't guarantee they'll make it in
although if you have a feature you think
would be really cool and then you also
submit a pull request for it then I'm
much more likely to bring it in because
it's already done
anyway so I think it would be cool I'm
excited about this because I think we
can really make this you know better
than the the current version that's live
and it'll be exciting so not only will
we be able to give users easier way to
sign in that's tied in with all their
other university accounts but also we
may be able to give them some new
features updated design
it'll be nice hmm yeah I think it'll be
really nice okay okay Robert also has
has pasted in this jitter channel live
coding with Jessie free code camp lobby
I'm gonna take this and paste it let's
go over here okay cool this is some
stuff I had from a previous stream so
let me let me go down a bit and hear
this this link is for the getter let me
copy this link over just to make sure
that it works before I give it out to
everyone yeah oh no
Bobby it's not working for me what did I
do wrong
all right is that link working for
anyone else git er dot I am slash live
coding with Jessie free code camp slash
lobby because I'm getting a 404 whenever
I try to use that
hmm
okay
okay I'm gonna wait a minute just to see
if that Gator link is working for anyone
else because I want not only people in
the live chat but the people that are
watching this later on I want to be able
to give them the right link so also so
Robert says can you limit the single
sign-on to IP address or can they also
use a link on home computer I need to
create the exact same thing but limited
to a word computer hmm
you know what I'm not I've never really
thought about that yeah I don't know so
I don't know is anyone have any thoughts
on that
how could we limit it to an IP I mean I
suppose it's possible yeah yeah I would
I was supposed as possible right I mean
weird I'm going to get to email address
so if you could grab the IP and just
limit it to the IP I suppose that would
work but what's the potential for faking
an IP address how hard is that to do I
don't know like how secure you need it
to be here let me put in the link that's
actually working for me right now
so this link is working so get ur dot IM
slash live coding with jesse free code
camp okay and then once you get there
you'll see let me show you on the screen
here so everybody knows how to get in
here you'll see this lobby and when you
click lobby then you'll be able to get
in and chat so off to sign it I know I
had to do have a git er login sign of
yeah I think I've signed it with github
so you can sign it with Twitter or
github
i-isn't not working there yeah okay so
here we go yeah
please join join up with the git er we
do still have our slack channel to so
that's available so uh you know if you
want to join that just let me know I'll
need your email to invite you but
otherwise the Gator channel is open and
that'll be cool so feel free
you know if I'm not streaming to ask
questions in here and the more people we
get in here the better we can help each
other out so okay I think that's it let
me check the chat one more time and
alright so now I have officially gotten
through everything and it's it's just in
time because I'll have a little bit of
time to wrap things up of course it's
time for me to go home and yeah so this
is a pretty good stream we got some
things worked out worked out some bugs
murder some pool requests hopefully you
all have learned a little bit more about
git and it's really helpful if you're
not using it I highly recommend it it's
I highly recommend some form of version
control and among the forms of version
control that I've had exposure to I
definitely prefer get so try it out if
you haven't already tried it out
you'll well if you force yourself to use
it and get used to it you know you'll
never want to work without it okay all
right so I should be back tomorrow
sometime around 2:00 p.m. Eastern time
so until tomorrow have a great day